Hey bosses, it's Winnie from Asian Boss.
When it comes to Japan,...
...one of the most common social issues that you'd associate with the country...
...is probably its overwork culture.
But according to the Japanese labor law,...
...only 8 hours a day which equates to 40 hours a week is allowed.
So, does the perception of overwork or death due to overwork still hold true in 2021?
How many hours do Japanese actually work?
This is the Asian Boss street poll, and let's go check it out.
So, here you have the results, guys.
Unfortunately, in the past six hours...
...we weren't able to get 100 participants to do our street poll.
However, according to the result here,...
...you can see that around 60% of our participants...
...actually work for 40 to 60 hours per week,...
...and about 25% work for 60 to 80 hours per week,...
...which is a lot higher than the 40 hours regulated by law,...
...and you can see that there is a small portion of people...
...who actually work more than 80 hours.
Of course, this differs from industry and differs by age.
It does not necessarily represent the overall Japanese working population.
However, we still hope that you find this quite interesting and informative.